تحتدم المعركة على مشارف طرابلس
، العاصمة الليبية منذ أوائل أبريل / نيسان ،
كافح المقاتلون الموالون لحكومة الوفاق الوطني غير المدعومة من أجل وقف زحف أمراء الحرب
حليفة حافظ ما يسمى بالجيش الوطني الليبي
الذي يسيطر الآن اسميًا على
معظم البلاد وتقريباً.  كل
نفطها يتعارض مع الصوت والغضب من
الكثير الذي تم التقاطه في اللقطات التي
قدمها المصور المستقل غابرييل لشبكة سي إن إن.
اليرموك
نخشى بالطبع أنه يقول ما هو
الخيار الذي يجب أن يكون في الصف الثالث بدون علامات ،
لكن جميع أصدقائه
هربوا والمدارس مغلقة منذ
أسابيع ، ولا تزال ألعاب الأطفال تشوش
منزلًا يستخدمه مسلحون في الابتهاج
الذي استقبل به الليبيون سقوط
معمر.  نظام القذافي قبل ثماني سنوات
يبدو الآن ذكرى بعيدة ، فالبلاد
منقسمة بشكل ميؤوس منه مع فرنسا ، روسيا ،
المملكة العربية السعودية ، الاتحاد  د عادت الإمارات العربية في
مصر إلى مجموعة حافظة بنغازي
والولايات المتحدة.  يميل الآن في
اتجاهه وكذلك في
الوقت الذي تعترف فيه الأمم المتحدة بكفاءة بأن
الحكومة التي تتخذ من طرابلس مقراً لها والتي
تدعمها أحدث أعمال العنف
قد خلفت أكثر من 600 قتيل ما يقرب من
مائة ألف مشرد ،
يقول المستقبل إن هذا المقاتل الشاب بائس
منذ أن كنا صغارًا هناك  لم تكن سوى
المحاولات التي تقودها الحرب لاستعادة الهدوء
في حالة بؤس ممزق ، ويبدو بالفعل
أنها تمثل أساسيات بن في ليبيا في المستقبل في
بيروت.